the annual security conference here in
Munich isn't just about the big names
and well-known faces it's also about the
special advisers who craft global
policies and work at the secret heart of
government my guest this week is one of
them he's Ben Rhodes a former national
security adviser to President Obama
after two years of the Trump presidency
how well is Obama's legacy holding up
[Music]
ben rhoades welcome to cult exam thanks
for having me
arguably one of the biggest upsets of
the Obama presidency was the election of
Donald Trump who set out to repudiate a
lot of what President Obama did why
didn't you see that coming
well you know I think most people were
surprised by the result of the election
and I think it was a number of factors
uh you know I think the first is that
you're Brock Obama personally was still
quite popular at the end of his
presidency the economy was growing and
it seemed like things were set up for a
Democratic victory in that election and
you said being with Obama gave you the
confidence that you were part of
something that was right yes was there a
certain arrogance in that do you think
no no I mean when I say that I mean that
you know frankly as progressives I think
Barack Obama and me tend to sometimes
think the history is moving in one
direction that societies are becoming
more tolerant and more inclusive and
that we're extending more opportunity to
more people and cooperation between
nations but the reality is that
throughout history there's always a
backlash to change there's always a
reaction to changes not just in politics
but in societies and Donald Trump gave
expression to that now the Americans
have been telling pollsters for years
before that the country was going in the
wrong direction and that support was
waning for political institutions yes
country like Congress for instance yes
it was down to 14% at the end of Obama's
tenure wasn't it yes so that that was a
warning that should have set off some
warning but when those trends had been
in place for a long time I mean I mean
even predating Obama you know Obama was
selected on it but he didn't stop it he
didn't stop it the the decline in
support of institutions absolutely not
and in you know with something like
Congress the radical obstruction we
faced obviously degraded in faith in
institutions Obama himself though was
personally popular so in a way he could
float above these trends and frankly if
he'd won for a third term if he could
you know he would have won and if you
look at the results of the election
Donald Trump got less votes for
president than Mitt Romney got in 2012
and Obama defeated him it's just that
Hillary Clinton got a lot less votes and
Obama did
Obama missed the bra power of Trump's
rhetoric didn't he I mean on a visit to
London before the brexit vote you read
about this in your book he told then
Prime Minister David Cameron when I
watched Trump's rallies I think how
potent his message would be from a more
skilled politician it was already pretty
potent by then wasn't it well you missed
that actually I said that oh you said
yeah yeah no look we understand look so
you missed it then sure but to be very
clear Barack Obama I think as as an
African American understood full well
the power of a demagogue and the power
of division and divisive nough some of
the threats and your questions I think
you can overstate that there was some
dramatic shift in public opinion in the
United States you know again Trump got
less votes in the Republican who lost to
Obama he was able to get the Republican
nomination that to me is the
radicalization in American politics then
he was able to defeat a very unpopular
opponent in Hillary Clinton and and I
wouldn't over-read from that that there
was some enormous shift in an opinion in
the country in the direction of Trump
there was a shift in opinion in the
Republican Party that allowed somebody
like Trump to become the nominee and
then there was an election where he beat
an unpopular opponent you said Obama
ended up pretty popular in the country
but for the Democratic Party he was a
major setback wasn't he over the two
terms he served roughly 1,100 elected
Democrats had lost their lost their
positions their majorities in the House
and Senate went by the time the Trump
got into power the Republicans were
stronger than at any time since the
1920s
well I think that what is absolutely the
case is that Obama's personal popularity
was not transferable to the Democratic
Party and we did make a mistake I think
in not doing enough to build the
institutions of the party during those
eight years he was assistant politician
he was described as a distant politician
well not too I think ordinary people you
know I mean inside the party well you
know in Washington you know I think
there was this idea of him as diss
but that's not the view that people in
United States are all around the world
had I think the voters felt quite
connected to Obama and he I think
uniquely among American politicians in
the last couple of generations was able
to forge a connection with people but
the Democratic congressman versus Gerry
Connolly was one of those who couldn't
understand why there was such a lack of
communication between the White House
and Democrats on Capitol Hill he said
people like me
Susan 2014 this was way into the
presidency people like me want to be
allies I mean I am an ally so work with
us reach out to us you know we're not
the enemy well actually say things like
that yeah we take one Democratic house
alone was he well I think we had a very
good relationship with Democrats in the
house I mean Nancy Pelosi I mean that's
the only way we passed health care law
the Wall Street Reform all of the major
initiatives in the violent presidency
relied on very close cooperation with
Democrats in the house I write in the
book that there was this idea that
Democrats or in particular Republicans
would criticize Obama for not reaching
out when he did they wouldn't extend a
hand in return I have an anecdote where
he invited the interest saying you
couldn't win whatever you did not with
Republicans you know we made every
effort to reach out to Republicans and I
think anybody who's fair who looks at
the Obama presidency would see that in a
Mitch McConnell or in the Republican
House these were not people who were
going to work with Obama under any
circumstances they had a strategy of
obstruction and no politician in Barack
Obama shoes was going to be able to ship
them off of that you during the course
of your time in the White House with
Obama you had plenty of doubts about
policies plenty of debates but you never
seriously believed to use that phrase
that you were in the wrong side of
history did you know on his last trip
aboard is President Obama the as
president if he suddenly asked you what
if we were wrong maybe we pushed too far
maybe people just want to fall back into
their tribe sometimes I wonder if I was
10 or 20 years too early and you in the
book you answer that question you say we
were right mm-hmm
where all that progress depended on him
and now he was out of time if you were
that
right how come you'll always be known as
the people who held the door open for
Donald Trump well look I think that that
I don't believe that's how will he know
I'd be living very strongly that the
future of American politics is going to
look a lot more like Barack Obama than
Donald Trump
now history did not stop the day the
Donald Trump was elected but his
election was a rebuke to the policies
that you stood for banned by over 60
million and well and with 63 million
Americans T 3 million no 63 million
Americans voted for Hillary Clinton I
was gonna say that
if the next elections rebuke of Donald
Trump and that president picks up on the
probes
well we already won the midterms I'm
talking about the presidential election
history has not delivered its verdict on
this and I believe the history will move
in the direction that Barack Obama
pointed us in that that's the direction
of American politics I believe that that
can be the direction of global politics
and that frankly we will be proved to be
right the Obama will look like the
person who was pointing us in the
direction that things ultimately moved
and Donald Trump will look like the last
expression of a kind of reactionary
politics that ultimately is on the wrong
side of history but Donald Trump
campaigned on the premise that he was
going to sweep away a lot of your key
policies and he's tried to do that and
in some cases he has done that and that
was a successful vote winner as far as
he was concerned wasn't it well history
didn't end in 2017 though and it was not
necessarily a successful vote winner
because he tried to take a part of on
his health care law and failed and
Democrats just take part of it then well
the basic law is in place in Democrats
just won a resounding midterm election
running on a commitment to protect
Obama's legacy and to protect Obamacare
the midterms are necessarily reflection
on how the next presidential election is
gonna go are they well no but you point
to the 2016 election as this seismic
historic event which it was well then
the 2018 election people were able to
take a look at Donald Trump's course of
action and the pendulum swung back very
quickly to Democrats and I believe if
you see that pendulum continue to swing
back people will say that in the long
run Barack Obama was the one who is
moving in the direction that the country
was going and in Donald Trump was the
one moving out
it's a big of course it is in January
2017 the Boston Globe wrote that the
consequences of Obama's presidency had
been stark as they put it a Middle East
of washing blood and bombs US troops
were embroiled in Iraq and Afghanistan
aggressive dictators ascendant human
rights and democracy in retreat a lot of
bad stuff you don't see it that way do
you
no oh look the Middle East was awash in
conflict when we came into office and
the idea that somehow Barack Obama
initiated those tracks it just didn't
stop it well yes he didn't stop it and I
think they were and frankly though in
terms of US troops there were 180,000 US
troops in Iraq and Afghanistan when we
took office there are 15,000 when we
left so we did begin and make
significant progress in the work of
extricate in the United States from
those wars but you're pretty kind to
yourselves aren't you when it comes to
legacy Obama put it on leaving office
almost every country on Earth sees
America as stronger and more respected
today than they did eight years ago
really yeah that was a big claim China
with his new fortress islands in the
South China Sea Russia backing
separatists in Crimea and Ukraine and
tacking into everything it could get
Israel Israel so you was more respective
I don't think so
they didn't Israel didn't if you look at
what he's referring to there if you look
at any public opinion survey it shows
the enormous majority of countries have
an entirely different view the United
States under President Obama than they
did under President Bush let's talk
about Israel for a moment okay but
because two hundred a second there this
is important there are 200 countries in
the world right yeah the vast majority
of them believe that Barack Obama's
brand of leadership was far better than
either George Bush's or Donald Trump's
you see the curve go like this under
Obama and then like this under Trump in
Europe in Asia in Latin America in
Africa and so we can talk about Israel
where President Obama had very sharp
differences with a right-wing government
led by Bibi Netanyahu but I don't think
that it was a judge it wasn't just the
sharp differences there were deep
contradictions in your Middle East
policy hood well we I mean you have a
core belief but you voted against them
to anchor in Israel this was rooted
largely in the Iran nuclear agreement
and if we had to do it over again if the
price of having a better relationship
with Israel was not having an Iran
nuclear agreement and potentially going
to war with Iran that it was not a price
that we were gonna pay and so we were
able to make a stand on principle on
this issue that did cause a rupture with
the Israeli government when it came to
things like settlements you voted
against your principles in 2011 the
administration Susan Rice said we reject
in the strongest terms the legitimacy of
continued settlement activity it
violates Israel's international
commitments devastates trust between
parties and threatens the prospects for
peace and just after that the u.s. went
and voted against a UN resolution that
used almost exactly the same words in
other words and with really only one
exception at the end of President
Obama's tenure you consistently voted
against your own principles at the UN
why on settlements yes at the end in
2016 we did allow for a resolution to go
forward that was never gonna be a
winning formula was it well again our
position in 2011 right was that there
was still a peace effort underway that
if you had a process at the UN it would
foreclose any possibility of having a
negotiated settlement between Israelis
and Palestinians
clearly that proved to be wrong I'm
trying to agree with you trying to find
a way through this no I'm telling you we
were wrong I mean I don't know how more
plainly I can say this we thought that
we could through a negotiated process
with these realities and Palestinians
test whether or not peace was possible
and that was not and we tried very hard
in 2010 2011 then John Kerry when he
became Secretary of State to negotiate
something between the Israelis and
Palestinians I think anybody looking at
this would think in 2011 that if we had
gone the route of the United Nations
that Israel would not have come into
those negotiations we tested that
proposition it did not work and so in
2016 when this came up for a vote again
we supported it let's let's look at
political courage in terms of the Arab
Spring because to an administration that
campaigned on a slogan of hope and
change the air
Springs should have been right up your
street shouldn't it but Egypt was a case
in point after the demonstrations that
got rid of Hosni Mubarak the old
dictator Obama backed the Egyptian
military council known as SCAF and you
quoted him saying in the book our
priority has to be stability and
supporting the SCAF wasn't just
supporting stability was supporting
repression because you knew by then what
SCAF stood for well and I quote that and
as one of the policies I disagreed you
know my concern with our each apology
but he threw the the young people the
April 6 movement he threw them under the
bus didn't well i backing the egyptian
military council which went on to
torture people with industrial
efficiency what i what i believe is that
we made this initial decision to support
the Arab Spring and within Egypt it's a
break from Mubarak and then I believe
that the habits deep-rooted habits of
the US government were to engage the
people that the US government knew and
that's the Egyptian military the
Egyptian security services and I believe
that that was a mistake I believe you
still believe that as you stand by the
way I'm I'm in a tiny minority in that
regard I think most people believe that
we should have been even more in support
of the Egyptian military but I believe
me after killing 800 people in a single
day in the rubble
look at the praise that is heaped on
president Sisi in the United States
absolutely and I but again a nice isn't
you being right you said was we talked
about earlier you thought we were right
this is a big instance where you weren't
right when I say wait and to be very
clear when I say we were right I mean
the orientation of Barack Obama's
politics the vision that he has for the
United States in the world I believe is
fundamentally right that does not mean
that every single decision that you make
in the course of eight years is right
Jake Sullivan who you worked with in the
White House former national security
adviser to Vice President Joe Biden he's
critical of the Obama administration on
human rights he said not enough was done
to elevate the priority of human rights
and reform in in the case of Saudi
Arabia fair criticism yeah I mean I
myself
critical of the Saudis I you know we
there's you he's talking about you know
but we did a you know I do think there
are cases if you look at our
relationship with Saudi Arabia versus
Donald Trump's right there is a reason
that you have seen a much more unbound
Saudi leadership in the last two years
we were raising human rights cases we
were raising cases of people who'd been
detained we were trying to report about
a Yemen war because Sullivan points out
if you take something like the conflict
in Yemen which is caused massive loss of
life it was the Obama administration
which began the support for the
saudi-led coalition in that effort yes
and big mistake but wait what we did
this way I think would be very different
than the Trump administration it was
very conditional support we would
withhold weapons from the Saudis if we
thought that they were engaged in over
extension we would not they were engaged
in over extension
breakfast and we pulled back this part
facie evidence we hope we held back
weapons from them I believe that the
warden Yemen was wrong I believe was
wrong from the start but I do believe
you have to draw a contrast between the
conduct of that war in Yemen after Trump
came into office and before Trump came
into office and what you saw is all the
constraints come off the saudi-led
coalition you saw a significant
escalation of that war you saw a
significant escalation of the risk to
the humanitarian situation in Yemen so I
do believe it is right to say that
shouldn't laughs Jake is yeah he's my
closest friend I mean we've offered a
letter together to Congress Jake and I
urge in Congress to vote to suspend all
US assistance to the war in Yemen and so
you know I'm obviously aligned with his
views but I do think you have to draw a
contrast between the u.s. and the
restraints that we would place on the
Saudis not just in Yemen but in the
region which caused many tensions you
know if we were sitting here in 2016
you'd probably be asking me isn't this a
big problem that the Saudis are so
critical of Obama's foreign policy and
that you have these differences the
reality is when Trump came in the door
they got everything they wanted the
blockade with Qatar is something that we
tried to prevent the escalation of the
war in Yemen the intervention Lebanese
politics and the accession of Mohammed
bin Salman the crown prince all took
place in the first six months after you
say they've got everything they will
Russia got quite a lot during your
administration didn't they they filled
the vacuum in the eastern Mediterranean
after your red line was crossed the
so-called red line of chemical weapons
usage the Russians basically kicked sand
in your face didn't they they gave your
forces an hour to get out of the eastern
Mediterranean before they launch their
biggest deployment there in decades
which you didn't see coming did you
well did you underestimate Putin no I
think the reality is Russia has had a
presence in Syria for a very long time
some people talk as if until 2013 or 14
Russia didn't have some deployments they
brought in more deployments but they had
been pouring arms into Syria for years
they also blindsided you in Ukraine and
Crimea you didn't see that coming either
well wait I think what they didn't see
coming is the collapse of their client
regime in Kiev right this is the
precipitating event but but you have
gaps critical gaps in your collection
into analysis of of what they would know
it that's not I look the do you have to
understand what happened in Ukraine okay
mm-hmm this was not some long planned
Russian invasion of Crimea what happened
was you had a Russian backed client a
corrupt leader in Kiev in Yanukovych who
did Russia's bidding you had protests
that rousted that leader we negotiated
something where he would step aside and
there would be elections Yanukovych
flees to Russia and then Russia moves
into Crimea but wait did but the way
you're describing this is not the kind
of thing where Russia had a multi-year
plan to invade Crimea they saw Ukraine
slipping away from them they saw Ukraine
choosing an association agreement with
the European Union but they over
dominance from Russia Russia being
identified as a primary threat to US
interests yeah and yet
Breedlove was able to go before a Senate
committee in April 2015 and say there
were critical gaps in u.s. collection
and analysis capabilities where Russia
was concerned so you took your eye off
the ball
well even some Russian exercises he said
we didn't see them coming you can have
even the answer I mean we were watching
Russia you were a national celebrity
advice yeah but that you're gonna
gaps anywhere I mean this was a huge gap
this was one of your betrayal angry but
right foes we yet we were watching
Russia the idea that we somehow weren't
focused on Russia
you're constantly focused on Russia you
can have gap but that was his view and
he was at the sharp end but but I'm not
saying that there are no gaps in him I'm
saying that in any issue anywhere in the
world you're not gonna have hundred
percent you know in intelligence
coverage but this is beside the point
it's the political objective of Putin
that is more important than you know
anyone intelligence issue it's the
question of water Putin's motivations
and intentions and his motivations and
intentions I believe were once he came
back in the presidency to push back
against what he had seen as multi-decade
encroachment on Russia's near abroad a
steady collapse of some you didn't
realize that until too late we realize
it pretty early belong before Crimea I
mean it was obvious when he's taken yet
he was able to move and you didn't even
see it coming
well in Crimea yes yeah well what do you
suggest that we do invade Crimea do but
he surprised because it happened because
of a chain of events right again it's
not like well I disagree fundamentally
with the premise that they were sitting
here for years waiting to invade Crimea
and we miss this you had a leader that
they backed that collapsed in Kiev you
had a leader in Yanukovych who fled to
Russia
this was a huge embarrassment to Putin
he saw something a country Ukraine right
on his borders slipping away from any
Russian influence and that's what
propels him into Crimea so even if we
had seen that you know a day earlier
it's not as if we were going to deploy
the US military into Crimea to keep
those Russian Special Forces out again I
think you have to understand the more
important issue here is what are Putin's
motivations and then how does the West
respond to those things Ben Rhodes in
the short time that we have left let's
look ahead to the next presidential
election next year
what kind of Democratic Party do you
think is going to be capable of beating
Donald Trump with his
massive following his dominance of the
airways his dominance of social media
which proved so devastating in the last
presidential election
what kind of democratic that he's going
to be able to I think the current the
massive following is 40% he's the most
unpopular US president to run for
reelection in my life he sets the news
agenda
well then doesn't they dominate take a
look at what happens with the world as
it is the Democratic Party just routed
Donald Trump's Republican Party it goes
from 140 seats in the house yeah and the
and won by the largest popular vote
margin in history of a midterm election
the largest Democratic victory in the
house since Watergate and the Democratic
Party is in good shape you have more
than 10 people suggesting that they're
going to be candidate yes we should have
a big field and in what kind of nobody
knows any of their names nobody knows
what they stand for there's no slogan
you don't know what does the party stand
for what's that name recognition in the
country that's all in some cases name
recognition in 2007 the Democratic Party
when we nominate somebody who is a new
face who is a reformer an outsider
Barack Obama Governor Bill Clinton
governor Jimmy Carter those are the
people who've won people knew who
Hillary Clinton was and Al Gore was and
John Kerry was gonna fight Trump's own
ground we're better to run with it in on
our message a new face to come in and
say that we're going to bring change
we're the ones who are going to pick up
the work of giving people more health
care but is more inclusive economy of
cooperating with other nations of
restoring America's standing in the
world that's the message it is popular
in the United States isn't the fact that
incumbents lose opposition's don't win
Donald Trump has to trip himself up for
you to win was it down from trips
himself up every single day right and
gets away with it he no he doesn't he
just lost in the midterm elections
dramatically right I think there's a
losing with his terms and still go on to
win so there's a huge overstatement of
Donald Trump's political standing in the
United States outside of the United
States I'm continuing struck by this
he's an historically unpopular figure
right now in the United States the
Democratic Party in every poll
polls the Republican Party the
enthusiasm in the United States is with
the Democratic Party the recent election
results are with the Democratic Party
and I believe that we clearly have the
better chance of winning selection that
does not make it a guarantee we had the
better chance in 2016 and we lost so we
need to have the right candidate and the
right message but I think we will ben
rhoades good to have you on the program
thanks very much
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]